d'ici peu les patients guéris de la
coved 19 seront invités à se présenter
dans un centre d'héma québec pour faire
un don de plasma sanguin
parce qu'il contient les anticorps
fabriqués par notre système immunitaire
pour lutter contre le virus
ce liquide jaune vaut son pesant d'or il
pourrait venir à la rescousse des
patients en phase aiguë de la maladie
[Musique]
le docteur philippe bégin coordonne
l'essai clinique au québec en
collaboration avec des chercheurs des
autres provinces canadiennes
généralement après quatre semaines on
atteint notre maximum nascar avec une
bonne capacité de bloquer le virus et
ont regardé ce plateau la moyenne pour 3
mois
l'équipe du docteur en dresse une vie au
centre de recherche du chum a mis au
point des tests qui permettront de
mesurer la quantité d'anticorps dans le
plasma avant de procéder à une
transfusion chez les malades développer
ce type d'essai pour détecter les
anticorps comme j'ai dit c'est que on
parlait l'autre jour avec un autre
chercheur 1,17 note rock et signs mais
il m'a répondu youssoupha
l'équipe compte recruter plus de mille
patients au canada pour vérifier si la
transfusion de plasma réduit le risque
d'être un tube et où la mortalité
d'autres pays ont lancé des études
cliniques similaires dont les états unis
et la france
[Musique]
le docteur budget espère obtenir les
premiers résultats d'ici quelques mois
il reste extrêmement prudent
c'est sûr que c'est une méthode qui est
prometteuse quand on regarde le
mécanisme la logique mais c'est pas
parce que on passe que vous fonctionnez
que ça va nous sommes enfoncés dans la
côte du col 19 au québec
l'essai clinique met en commun les
expertises de chercheurs du chu
sainte-justine du centre de recherche du
chum de l'hôpital général juif d'héma
québec et de plusieurs autres hôpitaux
et c'est dominic forget radio-canada à
montréal